So, influential people have high Klout scores like the president and Justin
Bieber. Now, let's say we looked up the Klout scores of 35 people who use the
app Bieber Tweeter, which automatically retweets Justin Bieber whenever he
tweets anything. If you don't know, a tweet is a message that people write on
the social networking site Twitter. And the Klout score is partly based off of
people's Twitter activity. So, let's say that the average Klout score of these
people is 40. Where does this mean fall on the distribution of sample means for
other samples of size 35? So, just to recap, you found that the standard
deviation of this distribution is 2.71. So, how many standard deviations above
the mean of this distribution does this mean lie?